these members of the kooky community in
India's manafort state are blocking
major roads they say they're being
constantly attacked by the majority
mateys
and they've taken up arms
we have to guard our village
our family our Len
so that we can live in peace from
the attacking majority Community which
we were living together since time
many years back
not far away these mateys are building
their own defenses
they say the cookies are responsible for
the violence and their numbers are
boosted by refugees coming across the
border from Myanmar
they fear the influx is changing the
demographics of the region and
emboldening kooky separatists
here too civilians are arming themselves
against what they believe is an imminent
cookie attack
illegal immigrants have been attacking
us frequently we don't have the kind of
weapons that they have we're very scared
of them there's no place for us to run
they've torched houses we just have
small licensed guns to protect us
the region has long been home to arm a
group seeking autonomy and many people
have weapons some analysts say India's
state and Central governments need to
intervene
those armed groups the weapons in the
society which is in circulation they
have to be removed first
and for that the security people the
security establishment has to do it
sooner the better many want to end the
fighting these mate are Marching for
peace but they also have demands
they want the cookies to identify
undocumented migrants in their community
and drop their demands for autonomy
Vinton Monahan Al Jazeera